so one of the one of the things that
people often tell me well you know
you're protected by 10-year professor
so it doesn't take such courage dr saad
well in 2017
i had to whenever i would go to teach
courses
on campus i had to be accompanied by
security who would then
lock the door of my class so that if
people left the room
they'd have to knock to be let back in
because of the number of death threats i
was
getting when i would leave campus where
my wife would come to pick me up
i would literally have something akin to
kind of a deflation from an anxiety
attack
because i didn't know when they were
gonna come at me
what upsets me about some of our common
friends is that they're not willing to
entertain that conversation
which by the way speaks to an important
thing in my book which is
the fact that you are educated and
intelligent
doesn't serve as an inoculation against
you being parasitized
by idea pathogens because many of our
common friends have phds
and they're accomplished and they've
written great books and guess what
they're some of the
biggest sufferers of ostrich parasitic
syndrome
yeah and that's not to throw anyone
under the bus i mean this is
this is purely just to i think continue
to try to wake people up
to some of this stuff exactly look
some of our common friends with whom i
have by the way yesterday i put up a
thing where i was defending richard
dawkins for having been the platform at
trinity
college dublin and a whole bunch of
people yeah it's crazy
people were sending me angry emails
saying well why are you defending him
you know how he was going crazy about
trump or how he's going crazy about
brexit
the fact that i defend him because of a
universal principle
doesn't imply that i have to agree or
disagree with him on every other issue
and the fact that i have to enunciate
this clearly to you
shows you how parasitized most people
are
20 years ago when you when you were
first teaching about this stuff and
even before that when you were in school
learning about all this did you ever
think that this was that you were going
to be talking about politics
because you you spend a lot of time you
know it's not that you're talking about
politics all the time but but everything
is now political
and you talk about politics on twitter
and when i bring you on or you go on
other shows
people ask your thoughts on politics are
you or does that seem like it was going
to be the obvious end of all of this
that because of the way it spreads that
it would end up there
no no i don't i would be lying if i said
i had the foresight of where my
engagement was going to go
what was clear from my training is i was
studying
psychology of decision making so one of
the things when you study psychology of
decision
making one of the things you do is you
study what's called rational choice
so for example if i prefer car a to car
b and i prefer car b to car c
it has to be that i prefer car a to car
c that's called the transitivity axiom
if i violate this order of preference
that i am being quote
irrational so part of my training and my
doctoral studies
was to study psychology of decision
making or behavioral decision theory
which by the way led to
a nobel prize to one of my professors at
cornell
richard thaler and so i come from from a
group of folks
several of whom have won the nobel prize
for demonstrating that economic decision
making is sometimes faulty
so it was already part of my training to
study
irrational behavior but what was a
surprise to me was that the
irrationality would seep its way from
this very
circumscript you know mathematical axiom
to politics to popular culture so in a
sense i was
trained to look at human irrationality i
just didn't know that i would go into
all these different fields
yeah have you been uh we we've talked
about this a little bit but since i
haven't had you on for
probably maybe it's eight or ten months
or some something around there
maybe a bit longer but yeah maybe maybe
even longer um
can you just talk a little bit about
what it's like just sort of in the world
of academia right now and just dealing
with other
professors and have you been ostracized
by other people and
and other other kind of headaches
because i think humanizing some of that
stuff
you know you're not just some spinning
uh neuron out there you're a human
you've got a family and
people you work with and the rest of it
it's not that this has no cost
some might say a very good looking human
but yes uh
a gorgeous bronze man
uh so i'll answer this in several ways
so one of the one of the things that
people often tell me well you know
you're protected by 10-year professor
so it doesn't take such courage doctor
sad well in 2017
i had to whenever i would go to teach
courses
on campus i had to be accompanied by
security who would then lock the door of
my class
so that if people left the room they'd
have to knock to be let back in
because of the number of death threats i
was getting when i would leave
campus where my wife would come to pick
me up i would literally have something
akin to kind of a deflation from an
anxiety attack
because i didn't know when they were
gonna come at me are the three guys that
are in the elevator with me
are they the ones who are gonna
decapitate me so tenure doesn't protect
you from that
tenure doesn't protect you from all of
the
opportunities i would have had as an
academic other job offers
higher salary i've been denied now
several years in a row a chair
professorship
which i had held for 10 years and it
would be a cinch for me to
get it renewed but because now how
outspoken i am and
as known as i am now a lot of people who
would be sitting on the committees to
decide whether to give me that shared
professorship or not
are not very happy with my supposed big
mouth and irreverent attitude
and therefore i don't get that shared
professorship that's your professorship
comes with a lot of money
but do you think it's because they're do
you think it's because they are so
infected that they're against the ideas
or that they
perhaps subtly agree with you i suspect
some of people in your department
probably agree with you
but don't want to publicly you know if
they're if they're the ones that vote on
you getting in well now they're screwed
so and that goes to the cowardice thing
that we were talking about earlier
i get that i get that a lot you're
absolutely right that the silent
majority i think even within
academia uh is not on board with this
lunacy but
but again the fact that they are a
minority
doesn't suggest that their diabolical
destruction is
not something to worry about right i
always tell people how how many
how many committed zealots did it take
to bring down the twin towers was it 190
000 people no it took 19 people right
so i don't need 9 000 blue-haired social
justice warriors on campus
to keep the rest of us be quiet i just
need a few of them
that are a lot more vociferous and
committed than the rest of us and then
they will cow us into silence so i think
many professors are exactly what you
said they write to me
thank you so much you're keeping me sane
i don't know how you have the courage to
do this i would have left academia where
not because of you
and then they will often write so what
do you suggest
i do because i'm afraid and then i
always tell them the same thing it
sounds harsh but it really is it cuts to
the to the truth
the the 18 year old guys who landed on
normandy
were not granted safe passage they knew
that 60 70
of them would be mowed down like little
mosquitoes and yet they did it
so that dave rubin and gatsad could sit
here and speak freely today
so whatever it is that you are afraid of
it is a lot less than the guys who
landed on normandy so stop being a
coward and speak out
it's so interesting because you know i
don't come from the world of academia so
i think one of the things that has
harmed some of our friends ability to
talk about this stuff is
they still want to be liked in those
circles you come from those circles and
you've paid a price i don't
come from those circles so that that
cost is very
low for me but what i find is i'm very
frustrated
by the people right now it's like look
trump is getting critical race theory
out of the federal government that is
incredible
right that's what what everybody what
we've all been talking about identity
politics it's like he's getting it out
of the federal government and the
contractors the feds can work with
he got rid of title ix that meant where
you know in effect there was no due
process anymore i thought liberals were
for due process
but it's like they can't give him that
credit so my my frustration these days
is so
aimed at at what was
my side that it's it's it's not a
comfortable spot to be in actually
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell